So this is a big deal that this,
that this happens.
Now I want to tell you a little bit about
the idea of the pillar because it's,
it's an unbelievably deep idea and it
orients us in ways that we still don't,
it's still orients us in ways
that we don't understand.
And in fact,
it's actually the mechanism
by which we're oriented or,
and if it's lacking,
then we become disoriented.
And so I'll show you some
pictures and describe them first.
Okay.
So first of all,
there's a walled city.
So let,
let me tell you that you could think
about that as an archetypical human
habitation.
Maybe it's a reflection of something
like a fire in the middle of the plane or
the forest or the jungle for that matter.
Although it's kind of hard
to get a fire going there,
nudge in a fire,
ringed round with logs and perhaps
ringed around with dwellings,
right?
So the fires in the center and
the fire defines the center.
And then as you move away from the fire,
you move out into the darkness,
right?
So the fire is light and
communion and safety.
And as you move away from the fire,
you move out into the darkness and what's
terrifying out beyond the perimeter.
So what's beyond the
perimeter is terrifying.
You can feel that if you go
camping somewhere that's wild,
you know you're pretty damn happy.
Especially if the wolves are howling,
you're pretty damn happy to be sitting
by the fire because you can see there the
fire keeps the animals away.
And you know if you do
wander into the bush,
into the darkness,
then you're on alert and you know your
Predator detection systems are on alert.
And so you could think about the
classical human habitation as two places,
one where your Predator detection system
isn't on alert and another where your
Predator tech detection
system is alert on alert.
And you could think about that roughly
as the distinction between explored
territory and unexplored territory.
And really the,
the founding of a place is precisely,
this is a lot of this I got
from reading your Eliana,
the founding of a place is precisely the
definition of a UN explored center set
against the unexplored periphery.
And you know what's
interesting about that?
So you can kind of think about that
with regards to the walled city,
right?
Everything in the wall is cosmos and
everything outside the wall is chaos and
you know,
but it also extends to the conceptual
realm because imagine that you're the
master of a field of study.
And so that's an interesting metaphor
because the field is that a geographical
metaphor,
right?
And if in the center of the field are
those things that everyone knows really
well,
the axioms that everyone
abides by in the field.
And then as you move towards the fringes,
you get towards towards the unknown,
towards the frontier of the discipline.
And as you become expert,
you move from the center to the frontier.
And so then you're on the border.
When you're,
when you're,
when you're a scholar,
a competence call,
you're on the border between the
unexplored or the explored an unexplored,
and you're trying to further that border.
So even if you're just
doing this abstractly,
it's the same thing.
And it's a reflection of the fact
that every human environment,
concrete or abstract,
it makes no difference.
Recapitulates the cosmos chaos
dichotomy or the order chaos dichotomy.
And that's why endow isn't,
for example,
it's the union of chaos and order that
constitutes being itself and that you
stand on the border between chaos and
order because that's the proper place to
be too orderly,
too much in the explored.
You're not learning anything too much
out there where the predators lurk,
then you're frozen with terror.
And neither of those
positions are desirable.
So,
and that's what you know.
And so you think,
and this is a concrete reality obviously
as well as a psychological reality,
there were reasons for those walls,
right?
Because inside the walls
were all the people like us.
And so that begs the question,
what does it mean for
people to be like us?
And then outside the wall of the rows,
all those people,
because they were the worst forms of
predators because people are actually the
worst forms of predators
who aren't like us.
And the wall is there to
draw a distinction between
like us and not like us.
And so,
and that was a matter of life and death.
You can tell that because I mean,
look at those walls.
They had to build those by hand.
And you know,
you do see walled cities that
have three rings of walls.
So these people were terrified,
but not so terrified as the
people who built three walls.
They were really terrified
and they had their reasons.